joined by the chief secretary to the
treasury Chris filth good morning to you
thanks very much India for joining us
good morning
emergency budgets are usually designed
to solve an emergency this one seems to
have created one well this was a growth
plan designed to get the UK economy
growing ultimately the only way that
families and households across the UK
are going to see their incomes
sustainably Rising the only way we're
going to see good new jobs getting
created and ultimately the sustainable
tax base delivered to fund our Public
Services like police health education
and so on is by getting our economy
growing that's what the plan aims to do
partly through tax cuts but also through
supply side reforms reducing business
regulation building more infrastructure
like Road and rail more quickly building
energy infrastructure so we're not
dependent on energy Imports those parts
of the plan I think all of those
together will get our economy growing
okay and ultimately put us in a much
better position okay so you say it's
going to be good for people and yet the
reaction on the market has been
horrendous and people this morning will
be waking up they were already worried
about Rising bills now they're also
worried about their mortgages and their
pensions well so what would you say to
that well look I think on the question
about interest rates and more and
mortgage costs therefore by extension I
mean across the world for the last
probably six or nine months we've seen
an arising interest rate cycle about
central banks around the world of
collaborates in fact the U.S federal
reserve have put up interest rates by
more than the uh UK's Bank of England
and that's in response to the inflation
the global inflation caused by Putin's
illegal invasion of Ukraine and in fact
one of the reasons why this growth
package is so important and why it
included tax cuts is to alleviate the
burden placed on households and while he
also confirmed the energy intervention
making sure that households don't pay on
average more than two and a half
thousand pounds this winter and indeed
for the next two years for field you
remember just a few weeks ago people
were talking about energy bills this
winter of five six even seven thousand
Pounds a year and thanks to that
intervention last week by the Prime
Minister and by the chancellor that is
not going to happen so we've taken that
action to protect households at this
time of unprecedented some other
problems as I've said we've seen
um you know changes in or turbulence in
Global Financial markets for a number of
months not just here but around the
world the Bank of America corresponder
just a minute ago
um talked about the bank of England's
intervention yesterday of course the
bank of Japan intervened actually in
their currency Market uh just a few days
ago so other central banks are having to
take action as well the bank of England
did what it was supposed to acting of
course independently and it had its
desired effects and by the end of
yesterday
um the market had settled down again you
say it's a global problem the IMF hasn't
had to issue a stinging rebuke to any
other G7 country has it yeah look I saw
the imf's comments I respectfully uh
disagree with them the response that I'm
sort of most interested in is the
response by British business
organizations who represent the
businesses the British businesses that
are going to grow that are going to
create these jobs and if you look at
what organizations like the CBI the
confederation of British industry the
Federation of small businesses the
British Chambers of Commerce uh said
last Friday in response to the growth
plan all of them welcomed it really
strongly because speaking for their
members they can see it's going to grow
our economy okay so so business groups
liked it and would you agree that
although some of the tax cuts were well
received you just went too far
well look I think on the tax question
um I think we had very high levels of
Taxation and they were due to go up even
further that was the previous plan uh in
fact the corporation tax cut wasn't a
cut it was just keeping tax levels where
they are and reversing a very recent
National Insurance increase the view we
take is that in order for an economy to
grow we have to be have competitive
rates of tax to incentivize investment
but also to encourage both very
successful people and also businesses to
choose to locate in the UK so I used to
be technology Minister until just
recently and you know the most
successful technology businesses in the
world and the most successful technology
professionals you know coders and so on
they can choose where to locate they
haven't got to come to the UK and by
having a competitive rate of tax
compared to other countries we can
attract people to the United Kingdom to
make a contribution to pay their taxes
critically and to help grow the economy
and create new jobs but the markets were
prepared for some tax cuts but not to
this degree was it really necessary to
scrap the 45p rate which only benefits
at the really wealthy anyway it's not
even due to come in until April it
didn't need to be announced now and take
people by surprise well I think a couple
of points firstly the top rated 40 40 so
now 40 reducing from 45
um makes us internationally competitive
it puts us on a par with a number of
other uh the only benefits the wealthy
um well it it's true it benefits people
who earn more than 150 000 pounds but
very often those are people who are
internationally mobile they can choose
where to locate people I mean I talk to
people who have got a choice about
whether they work and live in you know
London or Edinburgh or Birmingham or
whether they go and live in Singapore or
New York or somewhere and we want those
people to locate here in the UK and so
one other point in terms of the size of
that measure
um it amounted to about to less than one
twentieth less than five percent of the
total fiscal measures it was a very
small part of the package most of the
measures like cutting National Insurance
and cutting the basic rate of income tax
which were the biggest the most
expensive measures they made up sort of
80 of it and those are targeted at
everybody everyone benefits you me
everybody but but the truth is the
markets weren't properly prepared were
they for what came at them and when you
when the mini budget was announced it
didn't have the obr's independent
assessment of what it meant for the
economy and how it was going to be paid
for and that spooked the markets they
were badly prepared weren't they and
that's why well I can't comment on
Marketplace headedness but I can no I
mean sorry the markets weren't prepared
for what you announced you didn't
prepare the markets well I think I mean
quite a few of the measures particularly
the more expensive ones like the energy
intervention to protect households the
National Insurance reversal and
corporation tax have been sort of quite
well trailed in advance
um but we are going to do of course a
full obr scoring in fact we're going to
do it twice this year as we're required
to do by law once on the 23rd of
November that's eight weeks away well
once on the 23rd of November wanted to
be done properly
um and and again with the spring budgets
there'll be two obr scorings this year
which is required by law
um we're also going to be setting out
the chancellor rather we'll set out his
medium-term fiscal plan which will
ensure that debt government debt as a
proportion of GDP the size of our
economy Falls over time uh because we
are going to do this responsibly and we
should remember of course that we start
this in a good position as a country
because our existing debt to GDP ratio
that's the measure most people use is
the second lowest in the G7 Jared Lyons
who you will know I'm sure often
referred to as Liz truss's favorite
Economist said that quasiquartang had
failed to adequately prepare the
financial markets ahead of this
announcement I'm looking said that
quasi-karting Chancellor is in uh
constant contact with the markets he's
meeting the governor of the bank of
England on a very regular basis he I
think he's yesterday he had meetings
together with his colleagues with
financial Market participants I think
he's had several meetings with them in
the last week or so um so I don't think
I accept that but he is in constant
contact with Market participants doesn't
the obr need to produce its report
sooner than the end of November well I
think we're going to do this just in an
orderly fashion we set a very clear date
the 23rd of November they'll do a full
scoring of uh of the measures that have
been taken they'll update their
forecasts let's just do it in a in a
measured organized way that is the right
way to approach this and that's what
we'll get on the the 23rd in addition to
our medium-term fiscal plan
has the government made any mistakes
uh well no one's perfect
um but I think I'm not going to sort of
apologize for having a plan to grow the
UK's economy which will increase
people's wages that will create new jobs
I'm certainly not going to apologize for
having an energy Intervention which is
protecting every single household in
this country from what could have been
devastating bills this winter you say no
one's perfect to acknowledge that some
mistakes were made well look I'm not
going to get into this sort of um well
why not post-facto uh raking over but
the point I want to make most clearly is
the one I just made which is having a
growth plan to grow jobs increase
people's wages make sure the UK is
internationally competitive introduce
supply side reforms things like the
transport infrastructure reducing
business business regulation all of that
will make the whole country ultimately
better off and I say the energy
intervention is protecting every single
household in this country from what
would otherwise have been devastating
bills you say it's going to make the
country better off but what about public
spending you've asked government
departments for efficiency savings
haven't you that's right so on the
public spending side side two points to
make on how this gets paid for I mean
clearly growth is part of it if we grow
the economy it generates more taxes how
long will that take and we set out
actually in the in the Blue Book last
week on page 27
um it illustrates that if we can get our
economy growing by one percent faster
than it otherwise would uh after five
years that generates 47 billion pounds
of additional um tax revenue but we're
also going to be responsible with public
spending as you just um sort of
suggested which means first of all uh
sticking within the existing spending
limits the so-called um spending Review
21 limits that was a review done about a
year ago it covered Three Financial
years we're in the first of those years
now we are going to stick to those
spending limits so the efficiency and
prioritization exercise that you
referred to
um is designed to uh do two things
firstly make absolutely sure we stick to
those spending limits and secondly make
sure that we're prioritizing expenditure
uh not on anything that's wasteful but
on things that really deliver Frontline
public services and drive economic
growth people have heard so many times
before efficiency savings being sought
from departments this basically means
that
all departments are going to face a
squeeze aren't they but we found about
three over three billion pounds of
efficiency savings last year as I say we
actually we're going to stick to the to
the the spending and so-called spending
envelope we're going to stick to those
planned spending levels that were set
out a year ago over the next three year
period but we're going to make sure that
we're spending the money in the best
possible way and we're going to make
sure we don't exceed those limits so
with inflation at 10 your money just
isn't going to go as far and and
departments like the NHS like the Health
Service just can't cope can they I mean
Charlie Bean former governor of the bank
of England said spending cuts made
necessary by this mini budget could
finish the NHS well the NHS has had a
record funding settlement and to be
clear the inflation
um that is felt by the public sector is
different to the inflation felt by sort
of you and I as just consumers I said
it's a lower figure and even despite the
higher inflation that we've seen
recently it's a global phenomenon caused
by Putin's illegal invasion of Ukraine
despite that the spending envelope the
spending levels that we're working
within will still see real terms
increases public spending adjusting for
public sector inflation but we are going
to stick absolutely
rigidly to those spending limits because
it is important to be financially
responsible a lot of people are fairly
horrified by what's been going on the
market it's not least Tory MPS who some
publicly a lot privately have talked
about their discomfort should
quasi-cotting resign no I don't think
you should the chancellor has I think
set out very clearly a vision for growth
to get our economy growing that is what
we need and if you think about just
think about this in the sort of medium
term what we need is an economy that is
delivering the jobs of the future
attracting people and companies from
around the world to uh who are
successful to to work and to and to
produce jobs here and that is the right
plan and he's and he's fixed and he and
the Prime Minister working together have
fixed this energy uh crisis for families
they would we would have had bills of
six thousand pounds that's you know they
intervened to stop that and that's the
right thing to do and I think families
up and down the country will be pleased
they've got a prime minister and a
chancellor who have taken
urgent decisive action to protect them
from the effects of Putin's War when it
comes to energy bills